allora io prendo un 27 un 30 con 37 un
38 un 39 2 46 e 6 47 un salmone questo
c'è col salmone allora facciamo un
salmone consumano con salto di salmone e
un 120 934 però se mi può togliere la
philadelphia aggiungi il pollo 44mila
versailles con resti di due mesi passati
infine questa notte sempre di più si è
capito vendere certo ciò che sembra di
formulare abbandonare così sento sporco
dei maturi diventare così uno prende le
cose così e ne mangia quante le nuove
per proprio nella traduzione di ore o
che a mille come un libro primarie poi
lo freghi nata dal gruppo nomi ma tutto
voluto premiare la cina sta male e tu
allora io vado dire sacri tiri in 32 e
38 3 38 philadelphia kahrizak e sashimi
sarà calciare al 4 di tutte le salati
dante lakers don cono nichi risate e 10
55 mila avvocati e crudi è una coca zero
questa sera grazie
non faccio più
prego datemi una mano guardate
basta uscire
e qui che se non paghiamo di più devi
mangiare che mi dovrò fa la foto dice
che devo fare la barca del pedale
avete ordinato troppo su charlot gli
venite non sapete come finirlo adesso vi
faccio vedere come uscirne puliti
nascondergli sushi sotto altro sushi
fare la mossa del criceto mentre
nascondi il sushi nelle guance e finge
lo scià lance senza ingoiare ehi ciao
trasformare e sushi in un meraviglioso
orologio alla moda mettere sushi sopra
il menù per trasformarlo in
un'esperienza multisensoriale in 3d alla
fine spiace carlo optare per la mossa
rocco siffredi tripudio di pesce crudo
mossa ray charles nascondere il sushi
negli occhiali per un delicato effetto
vedo non vedo
oppure si potrebbe optare per la mossa
sherlock prendere le bacchette afferrare
il sashimi in eccesso lanciarlo
all'interno una vaschetta è così e
coprirlo con della salsa di sopra
ricordate la coca cola in realtà
è un ottimo corrosivo per chi uramaki la
borsa la ragazza la distacco
lei come la parola borsa
the sky cola 9 sono in fondo geni
a questo punto taglio a metà e
california e lì quel dito con malizia
per capire dove parlare condizionale è
ora un colpo di sonno e sa partissimo
assurgi nel piatto degli altri visto
rimpatriano con dei gesti delusioni sta
a quel punto piazzo il piatto sotto il
suo lui lo spiaccica io n'esco pulito
diamine ma non finiscono mai ma che cosa
sono solo gremlins che cosa faccio
frizzo e voi sapete la ferro sapete è un
potente insomma quello che egli ero
piazza sotto al naso
apre la bocca molto lentamente seguendo
il ritmo
a questo punto del fiondo verso l'ultimo
perso due macchie e lo sbatto nelle
fauci senza che lui se ne rende
minimamente conto come se fosse un colpo
d'aria tutto questo senza essere beccati
dalla cameriera
no
qua